most computer vision tasks could use
more data and so data augmentation is
one of the techniques that is often used
to improve the performance of computer
vision systems I think that can be the
vision is a pretty complicated task you
have to input this image all these
pixels and then figure out what is in
this picture and it seems like you need
to learn them decently complicated
function to do that and in practice for
almost all computer vision tasks having
more data will help this is unlike some
other domains where sometimes you can
get enough data that you don't feel as
much pressure to get even more data but
I think today the state of computer
vision is that for the majority of
computer vision problems we feel like we
just can't get enough data and this is
not true for all applications of machine
learning but it does feel like it's true
for computer vision so what that means
is that when you're training in computer
vision model often data augmentation
will help and this is true whether
you're using transfer learning and using
someone else's pre-trained brains to
start or whether you're trying to train
something yourself from scratch let's
take a look at the common data
augmentation methods in computer vision
perhaps the simplest data augmentation
method is mirroring on the vertical axis
where if you have this example in your
training set you flip it horizontally to
get that image on the right and for most
computer vision tasks if the left
picture is a cat then mirroring in this
throwing cat and if the mirroring
operation preserves whatever you're
trying to recognize in the picture this
would be a good data augmentation
technique to use another commonly used
technique is random cropping so given
this data set let's pick a few random
crops so you might pick that and take
that crop you might take that to that
crop take this take that crop and so
this gives you different examples to
feed in your training set but sort of
different random crops of your dataset
so random cropping isn't a perfect data
augmentation method you know what if you
randomly ended up taking that trough
which won't look much like the cat but
in practice and works well so long as
your random props are reasonably large
subset of the Arsenal image so mirroring
and random cropping are frequently used
and in theory you could also use things
like rotation sharing of the image so
that's the view
I'll do this too the image of distorted
thatwe introduced various forms of local
warping and so on and there's really no
harm we're trying all of these things as
well although in practice they seem to
be used a bit less perhaps because of
the complexity a second type of data
augmentation that is commonly used is
color shifting so given a picture like
this let's say you add to the our G and
B channels different distortions in this
example we are adding to the red and
blue channels and subtracting from the
green channel so red and blue make
purple so this makes the whole image a
bit more purpley and that creates a
distorted image for your training set
for illustration purposes are making
somewhat dramatic changes to the colors
and practices you draw our G and B from
some distribution that could be quite
small as well but what you do is take
different values of r g and b and use
them to distort the color channels so in
the second example we are making a less
red and more green and more blue so that
turns the whole image a bit more
yellowish and here we are making it much
more balloon just a tiny little bit more
variance but in practice the values are
g and b are drawn from some probability
distribution and motivation for this is
that if maybe the sunlight was a bit
yellower or maybe the info illumination
was a bit more yellow that could easily
change the color of an image but
the identity of the account or the
identity of the content the label why
should still say the same and so
introducing these color distortions or
by doing color shifting this makes your
learning algorithm more robust to
changes in the colors of your images um
just a comment for the advanced learners
in this course and it's okay if you
don't understand when I'm about the same
when were using in red there are
different ways to sample our G and B one
of the ways to infant color distortion
uses an algorithm called PCA this is
called principal components analysis
which I taught about in the machine
learning group India ml class thought
bulk machine learning course on Coursera
but the details of this are actually
given in the Malik's net paper and it's
called sometimes called PCA color
augmentation but the rough idea between
PCA color augmentation is for example if
your image is mainly purple if this
mainly has red and blue tint and very
little green then PCA color augmentation
will add and subtract a lot to red and
blue but relatively little to green so
it kind of keeps the overall color or
the tint the same if you didn't
understand any of this don't worry about
it but if you can search online for but
you can if you want to meet about the
details of it in the Alex net paper and
you can also find some open source
implementations of PC and color
augmentation and just use that so you
might have your data stored your
training data sort on a hard disk only
uses symbol this round pucker symbol to
represent your hard disk and if you have
a small training set you could do almost
any
and they'll be okay but if a very large
training set then this is how people
will often implement it which is you
might have a CPU thread that is
constantly loading images off your hard
disk so you have this you know stream of
images coming in from your hard disk and
what you can do is use maybe a CPU
thread to implement the distortions be
it the random cropping or the color
shifting or the mirroring but for each
image you might then end up with some
distorted version of it so let's see
this image I'm gonna mirror it and maybe
also implement color distortion and so
on and maybe this image ends up being
color shifted see you end up with you
know some different colored cat and so
your CPU thread is constantly loading
data as well as implementing whatever
distortions are needed to form a batch
or really mini batches of data and this
data is then constantly passed to some
other thread or some other process for
implementing training and this could be
done on the CPU or really increasingly
on the GPU if you have a large network
to train and so a pretty common way of
implementing data augmentation is to
really have you know one thread or
multiple threads that is responsible for
loading the data and implementing
distortions and then passing that to
some other thread will some of the
process that then does the training and
often this and this can run in parallel
so that's it for data augmentation and
similar to other parts of training a
deep neural network the data
augmentation process also as a few hyper
parameters such as how much
color-shifting do you implement and
exactly what parameters you use for
random cropping so similar to elsewhere
in computer vision a good place to get
started might be to use someone else's
open source implementation for how to
use data augmentation but of course if
you want to capture more in variances
that you think someone else's open
source implementation isn't it might be
reasonable to also to these hyper
parameters yourself so that I hope that
you'll be able to use data augmentation
to get your computer vision applications
to work better